une menace sur la coupe du monde de
football le principal syndicat des
pilotes d'air france a déposé un préavis
de grève de 15 jours à partir du 1er
juin
autant dire que le conflit pourrait bien
toucher le mondial le ministre des
sports appelle au dialogue social mais
pour l'instant c'est plutôt le dialogue
des sourds damien thévenot
les avions d'air france aux couleurs de
la coupe du monde seront qu'il plus aux
seuls
c'est en tout cas la menace que fait
planer le snpm le principal syndicat des
pilotes de ligne a déposé un préavis de
grève de 15 jours renouvelable à partir
du 1er juin
la rencontre hier soir entre le ministre
des transports et les pilotes n'a rien
donné
les syndicats fixe l'ultimatum au 31 mai
la direction d'air france un peu le
ministère des transports puisqu'il a
quand même une responsabilité là dedans
on déclenche une agressant sur les
pilotes
les pilotes se défendent tant que
l'agression est maintenu les pilotes se
défendent si l'agression s'arrête avant
la coupe du monde nous arrêterons notre
conflit
si l'agression continue au moment de la
coupe du monde nous serons en conflit
pour ses pilotes l'agresseur c'est lui
jean cyril spinetta
le pdg d'air france s'est donné comme
objectif de faire économiser 500
millions de francs à la compagnie cela
passerait soit par une baisse de 15% des
salaires des pilotes compensé par une
distribution d'actions soit par un gène
pure et simple des rémunérations
pas question répond des pilotes pas
d'autre solution rétorque que le pdg ce
nouveau bras de fer un de plus s'annonce
donc difficile
il s'engage au moment où air france
renoue avec les bénéfices 1 milliard 800
millions de francs pour 97
pas question donc pour les pilotes de
faire un effort financier même s'ils
savent que cette grève risque de ternir
l'image de la compagnie au moment où les
médias du monde entier n'auront d'yeux
que pour la france